[Musik]
ja fast sechs Monate Krieg in der
Ukraine und die russische Luftwaffe hat
ihren schwersten Schlag nicht nur im
Krieg sondern in ihrer Geschichte
erlitten nicht in der Luft sondern auf
einer Militärbasis auf der seit 2014
besetzen Krim wir schauen uns das ganze
erst einmal auf der Karte an hier unten
haben wir die Krim und hier im im Westen
der Krim die Luftwaffenbasis Saki wurde
hier am Dienstagnachmittag angegriffen
erst gestern Abend deshalb berichten wir
heute noch mal darüber erst gestern
Abend kamen dazu die Satellitenbilder
raus die eben bestätigen was dort
passiert ist die Russen wir erinnern uns
erklären es habe hier einen kleinen
Unfall gegeben mit Munition aber und
Zitat es sei kein Luftfahrtgerät
beschädigt worden jetzt haben wir die
Satellitenbilder die das Gegenteil
beweisen wir haben hier diese shelters
die sogenannten also diese so eine
halbbunker wo diese Flugzeuge drin
stehen und wir sehen sämtliche Flugzeuge
da drin die wir sehen sind völlig
zerstört alle Flugzeuge die wir sehen
auch hier unten auf dem Haupt Welt alles
wurde völlig zerstört wir haben
mindestens 11 russische zerstört
Flugzeuge nach diesem Angriff von dem
Typen su24 das sind erdkampfflugzeuge
und su30 das sind ganz moderne
mehrfachjäger die auch eben in der Luft
eingesetzt werden können und wir gucken
uns noch etwas an denn die Russen sagen
ja vielleicht gab es da irgendetwas aber
es war ein kleiner Unfall und wenn wir
uns aber diese Bilder mal genau ansehen
dann sehen wir hier oben und wir sehen
hier und wir sehen hier
Einschlagkrater also perfekt verteilt
überall und diese Flugzeuge herum
Einschlagkrater von etwa 20 Meter
Durchmesser das beweist hier hat es ein
Raketenangriff gegeben die Russen wurden
hier angegriffen sie behaupten seit
Jahren der Krim kann nichts passieren
wir erinnern uns überall außen rum waren
Touristen die dann alle zu Zehntausenden
geflüchtet sind von der Krim der die
Krim ist wir sehen es in der Reichweite
ukrainischer Präzisionswaffen woher auch
immer die stammen höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht aus der Ukraine wir müssen aber
auch wieder in den Osten des Landes
sehen dort geht die russische Offensive
weiter
und ist auch immer noch nicht zum Stehen
gekommen trotz der westlichen
Waffenlieferung trotz allem was dort ja
versucht wurde seitens der Ukraine auch
geht die borussia-offensive weiter wenn
auch sehr sehr langsam aber Russland hat
dort weiter eine Überlegenheit und wir
schauen uns mal an woran das liegt denn
es gibt hier neue Aufnahmen wir sehen
das hier noch mal ganz kurz direkt am
Anfang des Videos von Munition die hier
in eine in einer Selbstfahrer fette
eingeladen wird und das ist ganz
besondere Munition die heißt krassnopol
das ist das modernste was die Russen zu
bieten haben das ist lesergesteuerte
Munition die also abgeschossen wird aus
selbst falafetten wir sehen uns gleich
schon draußen aus der sogenannten Mister
s das ist so in der Art wie die deutsche
Panzerhaubitze 2000 die aber dann eben
Leser gesteuert ganz genau fliegen auf
Ihre Ziele und auch auf wenige Meter
genau diese Ziele treffen das heißt auch
eingegrabene Panzer beispielsweise oder
Bunker wo sich ukrainische Soldaten drin
aufhalten können hier ganz genau
getroffen werden und das ist einer der
großen Problemfälle für die ukrainische
Armee das heißt diese Mrs und ihre
krasnopol Munition wurden noch lange
nicht alle zerstört russland hat
Hunderte davon hunderte in der Ukraine
die die ganze Zeit feuern und die eben
den Ukrainern wir wissen das von
Präsident selensky erhebliche Schäden
zufügen und wenn wir sagen erhebliche
Schäden wir sehen das hier ganz am Ende
wie also eine Drohne den Laser hier
führt wir sehen das hier gleich hier
oben da sehen wir eine ukrainisches
Fahrzeug und wir sehen den Einschlag nur
wenig wenige Meter entfernt und wir
sehen gleich noch mal wenn es ein
bisschen mehr ranzoomt dass wir dort
auch eine da ein eingegrabenes
ukrainisches Fahrzeug hatten was durch
diese Munition da zerstört wurde und
auch eine weitere Waffe müssen uns
angucken die die Russen in den letzten
Tagen immer öfter einsetzen Kamikaze
Drohne vom Typ lancic auch drohen die
erst seit drei Jahren produziert werden
hier sehen wir eine dieser Drohnen auf
ihrer Jagd und sie jagt ein M109
geschützt was aus Norwegen gespendet
wurde und wir sehen auch wie sie
einschlägt wir sehen das ganze noch mal
wir gucken mal nach hier unten wir sehen
das Ganze gleich noch mal von oben auf
einer anderen Drohne gefilmt
in einigen Sekunden da ist es hier sehen
wir die Explosion noch mal in der
Zeitlupe wir sehen also wie die Lenze
Drohne der Russen hier in diese
norwegische selbstfahrerkette einschlägt
und dann auch zu Verletzungen der Kuh
führt das heißt wir haben weiterhin
trotz aller Erfolge für die Ukraine auch
sehr moderne russische Waffen hier im
Einsatz die der Ukraine sehr zusetzen
[Musik]